I probably first wanted to be an actor
but knew the household I lived in,
that probably wasn't going to be respected,
so that kind of just stayed in my head.
And then I liked the idea
of being a computer games designer,
and actually started to give that a go.
I used to watch certain movies that I loved.
I started to create what the computer game
would look like and stuff,
but I wasn't too strong in maths,
so that kind of veered me off from that.
So, they are the two careers
I remember early on aspiring to do.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.